[Music]
and birth party news ah submitted by
unlimited sushi women in Brazil are
having fancy parties during their
c-sections oh yeah okay that's not what
I was gonna look like
so they actually rent like their
birthing suites yeah but it's like an or
because of the c-section yeah and then
they'll build higher party planners to
create an entire like so oh so it's just
one mom at a time yeah yeah oh [ __ ] I
thought it was a bunch of women at the
same time I'm like how the [ __ ] did they
synchronize it's like 13 doctors in
there like one mom but then I thought
her guts are open and then there's just
all this family like what it is like
right it is yeah they're watching this
leave it oh no they record this the
straight-up cutting of you so what
happens here is when it's like really
really graphic the this glass turns into
like the fuzzy kind of glass
I think it's frosted but thank you it
gets rusted and then once the baby is
born and like wrapped and pretty and
everything then they defrost and now
it's clear and then everyone here is
celebrating and then they'll have like
decorations that's nice that's a
pleasant yeah and then they'll have like
actual like like what is it party gifts
our loot little party bags yeah and then
like actual sweets and legit [ __ ]
baby shower but exactly if I can start
the shower
yeah and then so they're just saying
like this [ __ ] is [ __ ] mega mega
popular in Brazil is it only c-sections
and not natural birth yeah Wow I
understand why they couldn't really plan
all that so what's happening here is a
hair - oh yeah well she's not even the
mom she's just a guest a cute party I
don't know if she's a mom but like this
is they're saying c-sections as a
percentage of all births by country
Brazil is number two with fifty five
point five percent
of all births in the United States is @
32.9 y so it's actually a a money thing
like so they're saying here by education
level so if you have more than 12 years
of education it's seventy nine point six
percent of people in Brazil getting C's
I see it as like a vanity item it is
only doing cause it keeps you tied in
[ __ ] is that one no it's because so you
feel fast you don't want your pajama to
go slower like way slower yeah we cut
through the abdomen right yeah it takes
like ten years you've hurt yeah holy
[ __ ]
yeah well five years oh five they say
like you can't even have you're a second
child through like that don't rich
people here changer
don't rich people here do c-sections
like celebrities and [ __ ] like yeah or
whatever I don't know for sure it's a
class thing too that I've heard of like
from my family members I thought you
can't ask for a c-section though you
have to like like my stepmom got a
scheduled c-section just cuz she didn't
want to go through the whole like the
unpredictability of natural birth I
think doctors prefer it to because it
cuts down on the amount of time that
they have to spend like waiting yeah
it's like the have you guys ever heard
of the documentary the business of being
born yeah Ricki Lake created it and so
watching that documentary made me think
like oh my god I want to have a natural
birth next time cuz with Isaac I mean it
was needed because he was breech
like his head was up here instead of
down there and that's like not a very
safe birth to have when the feet come
out first
yeah and so I had to have one but most
people in most doctors most hospitals is
just like let me just get this [ __ ] out
of here and it just feels so like you're
like cattle but in Brazil they like it
and they see it as like oh I'm so
well-off I can afford to have a
c-section and I can't afford yeah it's
the status thing and not good for the
baby right yeah I think I figured that
out that like it's out here for the baby
to be pushed out I mean yeah the sides
like medical cases were the baby might
die if it doesn't get cut out but like
it's healthier for the baby to be pushed
out my dad's Chinese science
believes that c-section is better
because then when the head has to go
through a tiny hole that you destroy
half of the brain cells this collapses
that's his Chinese is really good
protectors I found out when Tiger was
born
nobody would tell me like you know why
you're so smart because you came out
seasick so Tiger wants to come out via
c-section it's okay but he said he'd
take a smarter than you ever were he
makes that [ __ ] up - yeah well yeah
they're saying that um hemorrhage and
infection is more likely to happen in an
elective cesarean rather than in natural
birth and it's also so c-sections have
been linked to higher rates of
respiratory distress diabetes and Hut
high blood pressure holy crap yeah for
the baby I don't care if I have a loose
vagina which I don't by the way but
[ __ ] I'm going through that no the
trip I had a c-section and I said this
in the girl's podcast a [ __ ] podcast
but I noticed the difference in my own
vagina even though he didn't come
through there like it really does I
guess because of the pressure I don't
know what the [ __ ] but like it's not the
same did you have a you have a scar for
me is it in common that everyone gets a
scar after c-section or well I have a
keloid problem which so it means like
when I start like if I have a deep cut
if it gets bubbly and it gets dark so it
never looks like a just like a tiny
little line yeah for most people they
scar up well it just looks like a little
line you would actually avoid tattoos -
yeah I know yeah I know
so yeah for me I have like a keloid
c-section scar for most people if they
didn't have a keloid they actually it's
all never seen it's because it's
literally right above my pube hair start
it really you haven't noticed it because
we have to make it around each other I
know but I'm not really looking at your
vagina alligators either so you have
pube here the next time you should be
more not anymore because I lasered but
back then I did it okay so the next time
you should be whomp into that - looking
at her pretend your c-section scars
lower than I thought it would is it is
it from bellybutton literally I could
feel it to it cuz I told you I wanna be
scar yeah it's like right so like my
vagina is really shallow is it like this
wide cuz my mom's like it's like this
wide oh wait it's right here mom
shopping school medicine that mom's is
[ __ ] like the Joker from Dark Knight
it's like this oh damn oh she she
birthed you here
no Taiwan we also have a big head baby
right sorry mom she's tiny
oh you should call your mom or dude she
looks at that [ __ ] every single day I
try to call that as much as I can and
it's once a month right now we only Bart
to suffer mentally yeah I guess as much
as I can and it's one so much you're a
good son man once a month is good and I
[ __ ] love talking to her she's fun oh
then why don't you call her off I'm lazy
[ __ ] yeah I mean I really like the
the face-to-face with my mom why are you
summer yeah and I mean I don't even talk
to her on the phone that much I just I
guess I'm not a phone person you know
and while you grew up in that generation
before the phone yeah I think I would
only talk to girls to have phone sex
there's a pager mom
nah but we were in Japan like I would be
up to like 3:00 in the morning talking
to her and then she's like imma go to
sleep I still yeah she tries though the
others saying though that c-sections
today are much safer than they were
thirty years ago but yeah so like it's
just a big ol party that happens in
Brazil no and you know I heard too that
c-sections somehow create a slight
disconnect between mother and child the
process of the pain and also there's
like this this this I guess like
connection that the woman makes when
she's giving a vagina huh vaginal yeah
vagina birth does it make sense you know
I I can I can see that because the
moment I first held Isaac it felt weird
but I thought you're completely know I
might be able to debunk that because I
didn't feel any pain because I was just
on medication yeah like you get an
epidural you don't feel [ __ ] yeah I had
a very pleasant birth with him cuz what
was happening was Marie so me too I'm
not trying to mass plain and stuff but I
was just in passing I heard something
about how the natural childbirth process
without any medication Oh guilty that I
had a c-section I feel guilt that I
didn't work for yeah but she worked for
nine months then she took a break at the
very last minute it was hard for me to
get over that like I really felt so
guilty I'm like [ __ ] like I cheated you
know how he was celebrating this [ __ ]
did you uh do you still do that Golden
Hour thing if they come out c-section
like the hour the baby comes out
yeah they need skin on skin contact yeah
that's Pope's not supposed to be a do
digit you did that I just sat in at 80
sucker actually no no
actually they had me recuperate because
I they really did the name of my sister
my sister-in-law right away no not me
but like I didn't get to hold him until
I was in my room like hours it could be
me after I heard that I [ __ ] that like
we she was holding tight I took off my
clothes I jumped on top of them
I'm gonna do skin on skin too and then
the documents like that's usually I'll
do this but it's okay he's like yeah I
actually did feel really bad because
they bundled Isaac up and they put him
under that or not they didn't bundle up
he was only in in a diaper and they put
him under that heat lamp thing so he was
not covered up but I was [ __ ]
freezing and I think those cuz in the
Med like these blankets over me so just
like and they were like it so I kept
saying like I love my baby my baby is so
cold
he's cold right now I want him and then
they were like no he's okay you need a
rest so they didn't let me leave this
area until I was able to wiggle my toes
or something that's true because what if
you get up and you're like oh yeah I
don't know because they were they were
trying to have me press be done yeah did
you have Pinocchio legs your legs like a
puppet sighs Laurie no because over 11
years ago
oh yes long time I need to ask my mom
because she pretty petite and I wonder
if I was a c-section
they got old-school techniques man I did
this [ __ ] with no pain meds bro Wow I
don't know I don't think I'm all the
kids yeah like a couple of brothers and
sisters yeah my mom did no pain meds Wow
my what I would like to do sure well you
know I told Nick let me shoot you in the
head with that needle if they you like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you don't got to do all
that I try to do it right in like and
then you hit the bus see how long I can
hold off yeah that was never part of my
plan
yeah that's what I mean oh really oh
let's see how it goes yeah I know as
soon as I felt the first [ __ ] thing I
was like nope let's go
maybe you drug me up
[Music]